[Musik]
was macht die meisten reichen froh sie
sehen sich gern die armen wie im Zoo sie
kommen ihren Kutschen um zu schauen was
gewöhnliche Studenten sich zu sagen
trauen nicht oh oh oh er war davon weiß
seine Töchter intelliker
wurde statt immer heißer
die Kostüme des 18 Jahrhunderts
kombiniert mit Musik Sound und Tanz von
heute Hip Hop und RnB erzählen die Story
eines der Gründerväter der US-Verfassung
Hamilton ist ein Broadway Erfolg der in
Hamburg zum ersten Mal überhaupt in
einer anderen Sprache als Englisch
Premiere feiert
auf der Rebellion vibriert in new
York ich glaube Hip Hop ist salonfähig
also das ich bin mit Hip-Hop
aufgewachsen ich bin jetzt auch schon
älter und ich glaube wir wollen junge
neue Zielgruppen auch gewinnen und ja
wir müssen wir müssen uns auch wieder
neu erfinden das finde ich ganz wichtig
mein Mann
[Musik]
braucht mal duschen wenn man dann die
us-konstitution nein hört mich an jede
Sprache geben Musical ist ein Welterfolg
die Geschichte von Alexander Himmel
Hamilton schrieb große Teile der
US-Verfassung war erst der
Finanzminister und er ist heute so
aktuell wie vor 220 Jahren man muss
irgendwo anfangen nein niemals ich sage
euch ehrlich falsch gute Nacht hey wir
haben die Ukraine jetzt du weißt wie die
Situation jetzt ist und ich glaube wenn
man unsere Show sieht spürt man diese
Feuer von die die Geschichte hat und wie
wir wie sie gekämpfen haben und Freiheit
zu holen
[Musik]
Einheit und ich schreib sowas lieber
keine Zeit schreibt über alles sowas
lieber keine Zeit jeder Tag entfallen
sowas lieber keine Zeit sowas keine Zeit
du hast niemand eine Zeit Herr mitten in
einer anderen Sprache das galt jahrelang
als unmöglich und das Original enthält
viele Anspielungen und Zitate
amerikanischer Hip Hop Lieder Wörter und
Sätze der deutschen Übersetzung müssen
den Rhythmus des Sprechgesangs und den
Sinn treffen
Mutter schwer krank und heilt vergessen
manchmal hilft uns der Zufall dass
manche Wörter im englischen und
deutschen die gleiche Silbenzahl haben
so mussten wir nicht auch noch die
Melodie ändern
internationaler Flair in Hamburg und das
erfolgreichste Broadway Musical an der
Elbe für die beiden deutschen Übersetzer
Enden drei Jahre Arbeit
Musical ist okay dann hüpfen welche in
Kostümen rum und singen Vokale auf der
Bühne
so weißt du und jetzt ist es eben cool
also wir haben sehr großen Wert darauf
gelegt ohne Kevin hätte ich niemals
geschafft weil er ist ebenso der
Statiker und der musical-fachmann und
ein krasser King weil in der Szene und
ich war Kamikaze genug einfach
nicht zu wissen auf was mich einlässt
war die erste Musical Übersetzung und
vielleicht hat es gerade deswegen auch
geklappt ich bin ja eh jetzt im
Gegensatz zu sehr Musical ganz viel
unterwegs und versuchen unsere eigenen
Sachen hier was zu bewegen insofern weiß
ich ja was das Genre noch alles zu
bieten hat was vielleicht mal so in
Deutschland Mainstream Musical untergeht
und ich finde super dadurch auch jetzt
mit diesem Stück ein Teil dazu
beizutragen dass die Leute mitkriegen
was eigentlich alles möglich ist im
Musical ja und das ist einfach toll dass
auch die Musicals mit der Zeit gehen
dass sie diverser werden people of color
eine größere Rolle spielen und dass man
auch mit politischen Themen arbeitet und
dass man zeitgemäß ist und mit Rap im
Musical da bin ich sehr gespannt aber es
ist genau der richtige Weg der Schöpfer
des Musicals ist eigens für die Premiere
aus New York angereist Lynn Manuel
miranda ist durch Hamilton zum Superstar
geworden in den USA er spricht kein Wort
Deutsch hat sich deshalb beim Lesen der
Übersetzung Hilfe aus der Familie geholt
Maja maikas
meine Cousine Vera und ihre Freundin
Fiona waren zufällig zu Besuch als sich
die erste Besprechung mit den beiden
deutschen Textern hatte ich kam da also
an mit zwei ÖsterreicherInnen und sagte
hey okay lass uns das mal lesen ich habe
die ganz schön überrascht drei Songs gab
es zu der Zeit auf Deutsch meine Cousine
hat das gelesen und fands gut für mich
war das die reinste Freude ich kam
dadurch nämlich meinen Verwandten in
Österreich viel näher und man darf eins
nicht vergessen die Darsteller warten
inzwischen seit drei Jahren auf ihren
ersten Auftritt wir haben die ja schon
2019 gecastet und durch den gesamten
Lockdown hindurch habe ich die ersten
deutschen Aufnahmen gesehen und
gemeinsam mit meiner Schwiegermutter
gesehen die zu der Zeit bei uns lebte
die stammt aus Salzburg
das war also ein permanenter Test der
deutschen Übersetzung ich habe sie
ständig gefragt macht das Sinn ist die
Übersetzung gut und vor allem
verstehst du die Geschichte und kommt
das Gefühl rüber das war eine tolle
Zeitung
is brothersage
[Musik]
auch Liebe und Intrigen spielen in
Hamilton eine große Rolle drei
Schwestern verlieben sich in ihn
Heirat Affäre Trennung und immer wieder
das große Ziel des unermüdlichen
Freiheitskämpfers
[Musik]
er will die Verfassung der USA auf
solide Füße stellen keines Sklaverei
keine Ausbeutung mehr
[Musik]
Einwanderer Tochter weiß dass es nicht
so ein Zuckerschlecken ist aber es gibt
eine Möglichkeit und es ist natürlich
auch an der Gesellschaft das Aufnehmen
aufzunehmen ja
Alexander tut sich mit James Madison und
John Jay zusammen um eine Serie von
Essays zu schreiben die die jungen
Verfassung verteilt
der Plan war 25 es ist zu schreiben und
die Arbeit gleichmäßig unter den drei
Männern aufzuteilen am Ende wurden es 85
er
setzt am Ende der Premiere wurden es
stehende Ovationen Hamburg hat Erfahrung
mit Musicals die Hansestadt wird gern
das Broadway an der Elbe genannt
nirgends in Europa gibt es mehr
Darbietungen zur gleichen Zeit des
Londoner Westland und Hamburg
konkurrieren und diesen Spitzenplatz
und allen einen schönen Abend
nein auch Lin Manuel Miranda wusste das
nicht
das ist bei first Timing
ich bin zum ersten Mal in Hamburg ich
wusste überhaupt nicht dass die Stadt
eine solch große Tradition in Sachen
Musicals hat wenn ein Musical irgendwo
in Europa für längere Zeit aufgeführt
wird dann in London und Hamburg das sind
offensichtlich die einzigen europäischen
Städte die das fördern das war eine
richtige Überraschung für mich das hat
mich noch mal wieder dichter an meine
Familiengeschichte gebracht die ja in
Teilen in Österreich spielt
[Musik]
Läuse
wir wollen einmal bei dem was läuft und
das Musical betritt für deutsche
Verhältnisse Neuland ein Historiendrama
im 2010er Style beim primären Publikum
kam das an
[Applaus]
einfach nur glücklich gerade tatsächlich
ich bin großer Hamilton Fan und war so
gespannt ob das auf deutsch funktioniert
wie die Übersetzung sind und der Cast
ist einfach unfassbar normalerweise ist
so Rap Hip Hop nicht so ganz meine Musik
aber es hat hier so perfekt gepasst und
die Emotionen waren so packend die ganze
Zeit aber auch die die Musik also wenn
ich besser singen könnte glaube ich ja
nicht mitgesungen es war wirklich toll
es ist besser als ich gedacht habe weil
das funktioniert so gut nicht nur die
Energie der Künstler sondern auch ein
Musical komplett gerappt auf Deutsch das
war echt ein großartiges Erlebnis das
hätte ich nicht gedacht das war echt
toll
[Musik]
Hamiltons Geschichte endet mit einem
tödlichen Duell 1804 die deutsche
Fassung des Musicals muss sich ab jetzt
ihren Platz in der Geschichte suchen
[Musik]